how do we tell a story movies can tell a
story with a spoken word the
screenwriter creates the scene and the
dialogue to accompany it movies can tell
a story with the images we see on screen
with expression and movement the actors
convey their inner thoughts and emotions
that bring deeper meaning to the spoken
words wow that sounds so much better
than omitting actors spend 90% of our
time pretending to be other people less
psychotic but
there's a reason going all the way back
to the days of silent films that there
was a pianist in the theater for it is
the musical score that can truly bring a
cinematic score to life
adding incredible power to the words we
hear in the visuals we see and when the
score is in the hands of an artistic
master like Lalo Schifrin a good film
a good film can become great and a great
film can be transformed into an all-time
classic it's been said of Lalo that his
work cannot be easily labeled I mean
it's what he creates jazz this is a
classical contemporary popular the
answer is yes
it is all of those things in whole or in
part for each film and that's because he
adapts his style to what filmmakers need
and doing so Lalo has called himself a
chameleon and I agree in the most
complimentary sense of what that means
for he is ever-changing
not hoping that the story fits his
musical style but being able as so few
can to make his musical score perfectly
match to the film and thus the story
gets told
try to imagine Dirty Harry without the
music that accompanies Harry's key
moments he's throwing his badge into the
river or the moment they find the girl
to me the music is heartbreaking it
conveys Harry's pain and yet it manages
like Clint himself to be cool cool
that's a pretty good word to describe a
composer whose music helped define the
music of the 60s from the Cincinnati kid
to Bullitt - Cool Hand Luke and all the
way through to the films of the past few
years and today including one of mine
the bridge of San Luis Rey his haunting
score honors Thornton Wilder's tribute
to love and I'm so pleased to be here to
thank you in person mr. schefren let's
be honest without the cool Mission
Impossible theme I'm betting Tom Cruise
fails in his mission the first time
which means no next five sequels Lalo is
so many things a true renaissance man a
performer at the piano a painter with
notes a conductor and composer who has
scored some of the most memorable films
of the past half century let's take a
look and listen to the man and his work